[Music]
that's Britney Spears on Instagram
showing us she's still got it as she
dances to Billy eyelashes hit fat guy
[Music]
and yeah that snake she picked up giving
us a major slave for you vibes
[Music]
I mean we all remember this iconic VMA
performance and Britney remembers too
because she captioned her insta quote
great song it made me pick up another
snake well it's really you know I feel
like it's like therapy for me I just
exert all my nervous energy and
everything I'm going through into that
performance Billie responded to Brant
writing OMG are you ready for the next
level of superstardom no no I think I am
honestly no I think I I feel like I feel
like I am feel like I always have been a
little bit without really realizing it
your destiny
the 17 year olds also posted Britt's
video to her IG stories simply saying
Wow I love seeing these females really
taking over the music industry how does
it feel to really be a part of that dude
it's I don't know it's really sick to
see how things are changing and how
people are kind of like understanding
you know that that we're all just doing
our thing Brittany's post is just the
latest since her return to social media
in recent weeks it's been a
rollercoaster year as she completed a
stay at a health facility in April and
has been dealing with a string of legal
issues surrounding her conservatorship
we hold on to family when you go through
hard times like that but amid questions
from worried fans she assured us she's
in control of her Instagram for those of
you who don't think I post my own videos
I did this video yesterday so you're
wrong but I hope you like it
[Music]